شي بوقنا بالمره ننا
[موسيقى]
الفلسطينيه انا الفيط عائد صالحه عمر 46
عام عندي ثمن هفار ث
افاص موجود في رفع في منطقه الشابوره
خياط منذ 12 عام تقريبا فكرت اعمل
الاختراع هذا اللي شايفينه العجله على
اساس انه فيش بديل للكهرب هذا بديل للكهرب
لانه فيش كهرب ولا في سولار ولا في اي
حاجه فقلت بدي اعمل عجله الطفل اللي عندي
بدي احولها درجه الهوائيه اللي عنده
للماكينه ودراجته هذه اللي ليلعب فيها هو
لازم المفروض يلعب فيها انا قاعد بطل فيها
وهو بيشتغل لي فيها عليها قاعد كيف بديل
بدل ما كنت اشتغل فيها عيدي شوي شوي هيك
صرت انا طورت منها على اساس انه اصير اسرع
وقت واسرع في الجهد وع طول عمليه اكثر من
ايدي زي هيك خلت الازمه يعني تقريبا تقدر
تقولي 40 في ا الازمه هي موجوده لانه فيش
كهربا اصلا فطبعا جهد على اطفالي جهد
على كل
الاولاد وعلي
انا جهد مش طبيعي يعني على اساس وجدت
البديل بدال الكه انا اهم حاجه ان عملت
العجله هذ عجله ابني الطف لازم يلعب فيها
انا جته يشتغل معي فيها كنت بدي اوصل
رساله التحدي هذ انه احنا بعدم وجود
الكهرب اوجدنا البديل يعني ايش ما يسو
اليهود فيناش ما يعملوا فينا اليهود
البديل برضه
موجود شي بقنا
بالمره احنا
الفلسطينيين
ن